in indonesia's aceh province days of
unrelenting rain has forced thousands of
people from their homes
at least 15 sub-districts are affected
many parts of indonesia experience
flooding during the monsoon season from
november to march
but some people here told al jazeera
they have never seen floods like this
this time it's really bad we are taking
refuge some of us are going to our
relatives houses because the war is up
to two meters high in our homes
local authorities are providing food and
other essentials
we have resources in our warehouses and
so far it's still enough we're
distributing it to the people today and
tomorrow
he says it is difficult to know how many
people are impacted by the floods due to
communications being affected
the number of people taking refuge is in
the thousands we do have some issues
because many areas are currently
experiencing blackouts
thousands of homes have been damaged in
north aceh as well as a school
many have been evacuated to a nearby
prayer space
anxiously waiting for waters to recede
the head of north arches disaster
mitigation agency told al jazeera the
region has flooded several times in
recent months and that deforestation has
made the area more vulnerable to severe
flooding
as people struggle to cope more rain is
being forecast for later this week
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta